car sa voix a résonné dans on est à bord
autre chose
premier rendez vous du printemps des
poètes l'auteur laurent colons et la
lectrice frédérique bruyas sont
interprétées samedi 12 mars une
performance poétique j'ai créé une sorte
de recueil de deux monologues de poésie
qu'on a augmenté frédéric et moi
d'autres textes qui proviennent d'autres
spectacles sur l'appropriation de la
langue française notamment auprès des
migrants j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
des micros ont donc il ya un rapport à
nos langues étrangères qui est très
présent c'est en fait une création
vraiment pour ce thème éphémère qui
s'appelle à iwuy éphémérides de
l'expression
un voyage aux couleurs de la france et
du japon joué par le duo pour
sensibiliser le public au thème de cette
édition l'éphémère la parole par essence
est éphémère dix parents séparés sans
les mots disparaissent à peine ils sont
prononcés s'enfuit il s'enfuit on dit
c'est excellent être de la bible les
écrits restent et les paroles s'envolent
[Musique]
le printemps des poètes c'est depuis
2002 à la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines quinze jours
de célébration des mots et leurs auteurs
le programme du printemps des poètes à
saint quentin en yvelines c'est une
variété vraiment un petit aperçu de ce
qu'est la poésie qui touche tellement de
domaines
donc moi j'ai proposé un panel et ce
soir c'est au tour du langage autre date
une soirée caribéenne le 19 mars et un
concert du poète slameur orphée le 26
mars deux autres rendez-vous de
l'éphémère pourtant prêt à rester dans
les mémoires du public